delphine et jean michel vous nous avez
dit que cette année il y est mine de
rien votre bonne résolution
c'est donner un petit peu de votre temps
pour les autres c'est ça jean michel
enfin moi personnellement c'est en
vieillissant c'est vrai que je me suis
dit comment ça c'est triste un peu mieux
comment se dire qu'est ce que je vais
laisser derrière moi et puis on se dit
pas grand chose finalement qu'à vous dit
peut-être un moment triste mais c'est
comme ça et à un moment on se dit c'est
peut-être le moment avant de voir à
demain et quand même tel moment de
regarder dans le rétroviseur et puis
d'essayer de transmettre d'aider les
eaux d'autres façons de façon plus
bénévole généreuse voilà le découvert de
choses qu'on n'aurait pas fait avant
qu'on a le temps maintenant de faire
qu'on a envie de faire et vous vouliez
des idées une association de quartier à
distribuer des repas le soir c'est ce
que vous avez fait on vous a suivi
regardez c'est bien content de faire
partie m'a pas choqué parce que l'axé
pourrait faire les courses
ça c'est bien regarder sardines et part
individuelle donc ça c'est bien les sous
c'est bien quand il fait froid et coup
[Musique]
je veux dire un vieux couple de ça je
pense qu'on est bon à tout à l'heure
bon alors là on rejoint à mohamed et
aurélie ça va finir des sandwichs à
chanter
cours
du coup alors c'est vous qui avez créé
l'association les lui seul
et on en moyenne personnes dans la mare
pendant la maraude
oui si on tombe sur une cinquantaine
du coup nous avait amené quoi du thé et
du café des chips et chocolat des
gâteaux du pas m'y tiens
et il évoque trop sale
et
[Musique]
c est ce que vous voulez des pâtes on a
des super bonne pâte sa tombe
c'est sûr ça va tomber pour coiffer
un suisse
son
andré fait ouais
[Musique]
rien fait
quand ils payent rien
[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous faites
m
[Musique]
vais pas on voulait vraiment vous
remercier et bravo pour votre tempe
généralité voudrais ajouter les gens
fans quelques minutes dans la semaine de
pouvoir faire ici
une fois comme ça mais vous essayé deux
fois par semaine
nos bénévoles tous merci mohammedia
merci des tables merci mohamed est là
merci venez venez la venelle abonnés la
mettais book of mercy mercy aurélie
merci des ajouts fait un bisou merci la
balade des lucioles vous faites un
travail fabuleux vous allez vous balader
toute addiction
amel hôtels et chez sa mère elle est
bonne celle là
si vous avez lu que je frappe hors cadre
ce soir voilà il ya là il ya aurait dit
moi mais il s'agissait des fous ici
non merci et à côté de moi comme ça vous
aurez délai elle est dans la tête venez
on aurait dit je voudrais dire la balade
des lucioles vous faites un travail
fabuleux cinq associations que vous avez
monté il ya deux ans aurélie voilà vous
avez 35 ans vous êtes en couple avec
vous vous êtes en coupe et mohamed voilà
qui est ici quelque 43 ans qui est très
heureux et très bien que 13 enfants les
plus démunis et vous donner un peu de
lumière à ceux qui sont dans l'ombre
alors ce soir je voulais absolument vous
soyez là parce que je trouve que vous
faites un travail fabuleux et on a
besoin de gens comme vous c'est ce qu'on
voulait vraiment mettre à l'honneur ce
soir en ce début d'année
et si je tenais à remercier jean paul
moka traits d'une grande marque de
magasins alimentaires de proximité
je vous le dis qui a souhaité vous venir
en aide ce soir et faire avancer encore
plus vite les choses pour vous parce que
vous avez besoin bien sûr de beaucoup de
choses pour aider les autres et ce soir
on vous offre
grâce à cette enseigne regardez on vous
offre ce soir pour vous vous pouvez
ouvrir vous offre 19 tonnes
19 tonnes de bronze
19 tonnes de course pour vous ça
représente 40 mille euros voilà donc
c'est un don exceptionnel j'espère va
vous aider
[Applaudissements]
non mais c'est vous qui faites un
travail pas mieux fait
non mais moi je les regrette je n'ai
vraiment mettre votre association ce
soir en lumière les gars vous faites un
travail le et nous nous on fait rien ne
sait rien ce qu'on fait par rapport à ce
que vous faites tous les jours non non
on ne sait rien non mais c'est rien par
rapport à ce qu'on vous fait savoir que
tout ça ça va vraiment vraiment nous
aider parce que sur le terrain vous avez
vu les moyens qu'on a
c'est ça sent vraiment très très peu
style très restreint là avec tout ça on
va pouvoir
ça va être noël pour tout le monde là un
bravo à vous alors jamais ses forces
pour aller normalement et jouer je
voulais juste vous lire nous dit pas
merci parce que c'est grâce à votre
travail qu'on fait tous les ans et on a
été touché par votre association et nous
ce que je voudrais c'est les bénévoles
ce que c'est vrai qu'elle a créé
l'association mais sans les bénévoles et
sans nos partenaires aussi on n'aurait
rien du tout et ben voilà on voulait
vous et dès ce soir
la balade de new soul simulation est
bénévole et et des royés mohamed
n'hésitez pas à votre lit m au bas de
l'écran merci aurélie et mohamed et
continuer la personne fait voilà ça nous
n'hésitez pas à les contacter sur
facebook si vous voulez vous travailler
avec eux les vendredis on fait des
maraudes toute l'année et c'est sain
c'est un secteur où alors vers cadets
vers saint lazare
merci à vous deux merci merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]